hi good morning everybody and thank you
for being here so early
thank you I'm David Brenner I'm going to
give you a talk on I imagine what is an
unexpected title I'm going to claim that
classical Chinese is a programming
language in some sense and I'll try to
prove that to you today oh I should tell
you at the outset the the type on this
screen is not going to get any smaller
than this but it's also not going to get
bigger and if you're having trouble
seeing there are still seats in the
front maybe you would like to squeeze up
so I'm gonna use the word Chinese and
sometimes the word classical Chinese
here I may use it carelessly so I want
to say at the outset what it is that I'm
talking about classical Chinese or
literary Chinese is the written language
of most of Chinese history it was the
main language of communication and diary
writing and inscriptions until somewhere
in the middle of the 20th century if you
look at the larger Chinese world it's
not Mandarin Mandarin is a spoken
language classical or literary Chinese
is a written language only and it may
never have had a real spoken form people
argue about this because there were
there were no recordings unfortunately
but even if it was read aloud if it was
used to some extent in speech at court
where you had to be very formal it
almost certainly belonged to what is
called a high diglossic register and all
that means is that it was always
connected even when it came out of
people's mouths it was always connected
to writing so we're dealing with
something different from what most of us
experienced now very few of us ever deal
with an entirely written natural
language like Latin or Greek I think
very few people do that now so this
language classical Chinese this written
language has had an enormous effect on
Mandarin this the standard spoken
language
of China words the way they're formed to
a great extent follow the rules that I'm
going to describe today in addition the
grammar of Mandarin can be built on top
of the basis that I'm describing you
need other rules but this is a good
foundation and furthermore this this
classical Chinese thing is also found in
the the literate languages around China
in particular Korea and Japan and
Vietnam until fairly recently there's a
lot of Chinese vocabulary in those
languages it's fully assimilated and so
the same principles of word formation
apply okay so I'm going to claim that
classical Chinese grammar has
approximately the order of simplicity
formal simplicity of a programming
language rather than that of a natural
language and I'll show you what I mean
I'll try to show this at least using a
context-free grammar which I'll describe
during the next half hour and then I'll
show you how because it you get a lot of
ambiguity when you have a highly
compressed language like this little
things little tweaks can be done to
reduce the ambiguity so that's that's
the point of this so what is this
language Chinese made of it's made of
words and in order to talk about grammar
we have to talk about the types of words
and in natural languages the type of a
word is called it's part of speech and
we abbreviate that as POS so I'll
probably use that throughout the slides
we having Chinese nouns and verbs
basically that's basically all we have
it's a great system to type system nouns
I think everybody knows this word a noun
is a person place or thing or it could
be the name of a person place or thing
and for example in Chinese you know you
don't need to pronounce it with me yes
here is the Sun it also means day it is
written with this character the
characters will show up here so that I
know what I'm talking about
and Chinese readers will know what I'm
talking about but it's not part of the
talk Sun or day it's in now right it's a
it's a thing but the root or trunk of a
tree it can also mean a fundamental
issue it's very common in philosophy to
talk about the bun or even you know
capital in the economic sense is been
the the foundation of of resources B is
a kind of hunting net with long handles
used in antiquity and here's the state
of rule which is in southern China
around the Wuhan area true okay so these
are nouns no big deal and a verb can be
an action as you would expect it can
also be a state and we associate States
in English with adjectives but in
classical Chinese there's a good case to
be made that there's no difference
between what we consider an adjective
and what we consider a verb they're all
verbs so if I take this word for day and
I make it into a verb what do I get
well one of the meanings is to last for
a day to endure one day in duration
button fundamental issue well to treat
as the fundamental issue that's a verb
right it's an actions it's a actually an
action of the mind something that you do
in your view how about be the hunting
net what can I make what kind of verb
can I make out of this hunting that but
to hunt with such a hunting net right
it's very straightforward go hunting
with a bean that there's another way to
write it but it's the same word and chew
the state of Chu here and there appears
as a verb which means to behave as is
appropriate in the state of Chu maybe to
speak to language or to do the true
things whatever those are so this is
pretty straightforward these are all
words that I think we agree
intrinsically they seem to be nouns but
the verb exists the
must be derived from the noun the noun
is being used as a verb fine it's not a
big deal but let's observe that this is
happening and the other thing happens -
you can get what seems to be a verb an
action or a state intrinsically and you
find it has noun usage - and just a few
examples in - change or be changed and
as a noun
well a change or especially a sudden
change of political upheaval an
earthquake chime to give birth or be
born you like that the active and
passive forms are the same that's very
nice - as a noun product production
industry want to hope for gays out here
to look at the moon you know aspiration
or prestige how you are gazed at by
those below so fine you have nouns and
you have verbs but the nouns can be
verbs and the verbs can be nouns how do
you know what you're looking at actually
before you have context you have
practice but context is it yeah it's
actually a much easier thing to learn
than programming languages but it's
mostly memorization but thinking is not
as hard as programming but the the work
is the labor is greater so context is
the sole thing that determines whether a
word is a verb or a noun and I think
that's pretty interesting we don't have
a lot of languages like that when you're
reading and as a teacher the thing that
I try to inculcate is you you often hold
a lot of words in your mind not quite
settled as to their part of speech until
sometimes it bounces down it kind of
shakes down and I'll try to give you
some examples I have a little trouble
with the formatting I shouldn't have
used latech but there it goes I wanted
syntax trees with lots of things and
we'll see how it works toward the end of
the talk here's the take home but please
don't leave just yet classical Chinese
part of speech it's indeterminate its
malleable it's completely flexible it's
completely dependent
context even if in our souls we feel
that its intrinsic that Sun is
intrinsically a noun of course it's a
noun but in Chinese really there is no
way to say in classical Chinese no way
to say yes it's only a noun
it can be a verb just as easily so is it
weird to use a noun as a verb or a verb
as and now and we do this in English
quite a lot you can I something you know
you can I you can I a key right they I'd
my keys and you can actually make a
parlour game out of this you can then
key a truck or car that has parking
you're right that's not encouraging
vandalism but you can key things right
and of course we code we also key things
in you can truck things right it could
truck a load of palm trees at load of
Palms and you can palm things you could
palm a coin you can coin a phrase you
could phrase a question question
someone's right and so on you can write
a boat you can boat on the weekend you
can weekend in the Hamptons and you can
go on and on until yes someone
challenges you and says no that can't be
made into a verb and then you lose the
parlor game but um so the point is
English is able to do this to an extent
what Chinese is doing English is able to
but English itself is pretty unusual in
this respect and if you look at other
languages if you look at Greek if you
look at even Spanish German and to say
nothing of things like polish Slavic
languages Hindi Japanese you simply
cannot take a formed noun and use it
without change as a verb or vice versa
Chinese you do this all the time English
yes we can be we can taste what it's
like in English so in Chinese
essentially every word that is not a
grammar particle in classical Chinese
can do this so just this is really a
philosophy question should we say
there's no difference between nouns and
verbs in classical Chinese I think we
shouldn't say that I think it's better
to keep to point
in mind one is that of ourselves we feel
that there is a difference between noun
quality and verb quality we feel that
very strongly we should recognize that
because it can lead us into error
because of the second point which is
that it is behavior that determines
whether something is a noun or verb
behavior in a particular context and
let's look at some contexts now so is to
make it clear so we have atomic noun and
verb units let's say there one character
in length let's say there one syllable
and how can they be fit together well if
we're talking about a pair of them a
group of two you have four possibilities
all the combinations with replacement v
Vav N and V and n are attested and they
all have meaning so let me just give you
one sample of each to taste
here's the word Chilean it is a compound
of two verbs I judge Ching to be clear
like water or like your thoughts Lian to
be honest and Chilean is in reference to
an official to be in corrupt so to be
clear and to be honest that becomes a
verb to be in corrupt okay like her lie
to come a verb cool a guest well it can
be a verb too but we'll just call it a
noun for now so like her as a verb
phrase means to have guests it means for
there to have come guests essentially
boom father-mother right we don't say
that we say father and mother but notice
that this language doesn't always need
to put an and word in it can you can
just say father mother and you're saying
parents all right it's straightforward
and shin Swan here's a wonderful word
shin heart Swan to be sour to feel
aggrieved all right now so here are all
the ways that in two slots verb and noun
can combine and each of the resulting
compounds
I have also classified as two verb or
noun normally if we were dealing with a
natural language the tradition is to
write verb phrase should have said VP or
NP verb phrase or noun phrase but I have
a reason for not doing that the reason
is that I want to show you that no
matter how much compounding you do you
still always end up with a noun or a
verb so here is Shin we saw it a second
ago a noun harsh or mind here's Cole
mouth chinko it means what you think and
say that's pretty clear rule a verb to
be comparable to to be like eat what's
the number one
I'm never clear whether we should treat
the numerals as verbs or nouns I lean to
saying they feel to me more
intrinsically verbal but as I said
that's the thing I have to remember to
be careful of in any case if it is a
verb to start I'm asserting that it is
becoming the renowned one the object one
ruie to be as one to be comparable to
one to be like one you can then put
these two pieces together the now
machine code what one thinks and says
and the verb rule and you get Cinco ruie
which is a verbal phrase again to say
what one really thinks and I think the
derivation is clear we're doing this
passively we're not you know producing
new forms but it's quite interesting to
me that I I don't really have need for
any parts
speech other than verb and noun in order
to talk about all of this so combining
items that I take out of the part of
speech set verb and noun just produces
more examples from the same set so it is
possible now you're gonna challenge me I
need to give you thousands of examples
and then you find a counter example
among them but I I assert that because
of this pattern this kind of behavior
definitions of verb and noun in this
language can be recursive in character
so what I wanted you to describe a
language is to construct I said I would
use a context-free grammar there's a
reason for choosing this a context-free
grammar is a set of rules that describe
how the pieces of the language work
together to produce new pieces it is
what 60 years old it came out of the
mind of know'm Tomsky he he used it as a
foil he argued when he presented this he
brought it up and he said this is no
good for describing languages and he
explained why what he wanted to do is he
wanted to sell something he wanted to
sell transformational grammar a much
more elaborate and complicated thing so
he introduced this thing that he called
phrase structure grammar and it turned
out to be enormous ly useful to people
like us in working with symbolic systems
which computer languages are
representative of and he published
important writings on this the Chomsky
grammar and the Chomsky hierarchy are
terms that you encounter if you study
theoretical computer science it comes
from this 1956 article here he is this
is about how he looked at the time of
his paper a young recent graduate okay
so here is what a traditional
linguistically oriented context-free
grammar looks like this comes right out
of Chomsky's
paper it's a tree the root or as Donald
Knuth has said since trees don't grow
from the ceiling the stem of the tree is
a sentence the whole thing and we can
analyze it in two parts a noun phrase
and a verb phrase in this case the noun
phrase has two actual words I've
bold-faced them actual words that are
leaves in a tree like this are called
terminals and the verb phrase has verb
and it has a noun phrase after it it's
all quite clear the point of terminals
is they can't have anything below them
they are intrinsically leaf nodes no
further processes act on them in the
context-free grammar model to produce
new kinds of things so if you write out
the rules that are embedded into this
tree you get rules like this you say
sentence can be rewritten as NP VP VP
can be written as a verb NP and so on
when you get to things like the man the
book and took they can't be rewritten
anymore those are terminals and once all
of your turn all of your leaves are
filled with terminals you have finished
sentence so the key ideas in what
Chomsky was presenting is a we have
terminals and non terminals and
non-terminals can be reanalyzed he
called it rewriting until terminals are
reached that's what it's about that's
how you make the grammar of course it
has to fit the evidence but you and I
have recursion available as I showed you
in classical Chinese so we don't need to
distinguish terminals and non-terminals
at all let me show you how I would write
rule for what I described earlier the
interchangeability if part of speech
noun and verb
well noun can be reanalyzed this verb
and verb can be reanalyzed as now these
are rules that apply and here I have
just stated it in the the sort of flat
form of the context-free grammar
the fact that this recursion shows up in
the fact that a given part of speech can
be on either side of this arrow let me
put in the two syllable forms that I
described a little while ago you know
the the Shin Swan be aggrieved and so on
we have these basically among the verbs
we have three things and among the nouns
we have this one thing this was full
more at the bottom was parents was noun
okay so yeah and I didn't want to say
sentence any more because since we're
being recursive we don't care where we
start in the analysis wherever we start
that becomes the stem of the tree that's
a string of some sort okay so some
characteristics of this system to
reiterate now the verb types in context
are interchangeable or rather I should
have said out of context they're
interchangeable depending on context
second combination with repetition to
produce two element groups and there's a
third thing that I'll introduce on this
slide weighting of the elements what
does that mean each pair of parts of
speech can either be as I showed it to
you plane or there can be a subordinate
relationship in which the first one
describes the second one the second one
is the main one and let me show you just
what it looks like I'll use the same
format here Chinkin Chien to be clear
time to chat well this means to chat in
a clear way to chat with clarity it
means specifically to chat about
philosophy it comes from this word comes
from a particular time but clear
modifies it is subordinate to time the
second syllable which is the main point
of the compound if you had to say what's
going on well chatting is going on well
how is it going on well it's going on in
a clear way but clear we want to say
this as an adverb
we don't need to because there's nothing
intrinsically adverbial about it it is
verbal in quality and it's describing
how chat takes place another example
like we saw this word before well to
come plus guests can mean a visitor I
said earlier it can mean to have
visitors so it's the same issue that the
verb and the noun they're
interchangeable the derivations are
different for the two different meanings
that this one word can have this turns
out to be extremely common even in
compounds here's another one Tong Jian
Tong dynasty plus sound we're really
talking about sound it's described by
Tom the sound of the Tong that's that
means Tong poetry so and hear oneself
and to know to know is the main thing to
possess knowledge of self it is in a
self word direction perhaps self wise
knowing to know in a self wise way so
the self just simply modifies the action
of two now so if I add this extra
feature that I just described wait
here's what I end up with we now have
six items in the verb category we have
five in the noun and that is classical
Chinese grammar that's all there is
that's all we can do it turns out that's
all we need to do if we know how these
things are applied this does not look
like a natural language as analyzed by a
more complicated linguistic system like
transformational grammar or what have
you I mean structuralism there is
something structuralist about this
actually I think that one of the reasons
Chomsky wanted to attack this is it
looks very structural the structures
liked his teachers were all
structuralists they liked very neat
systems like this because we have
recursion we can build very complex
strings with these few forms but this is
the whole of the grammar
he said with a caveat that he would say
later we usually don't see recursion
going down very very deeply because this
has to be processed by a human mind so
you know two or three levels down and
they don't go any further
usually there are sequences of things
they're series of verbal expressions and
the whole thing is loose and very poetic
but the point is all the possibilities
given these two units vnn given waiting
and given two spots we have all eight
possibilities produced filled out them
and each one is distinct and each one is
meaningful so I had like who I had this
expression that had two different ways
to analyze it to have guests or a guest
from elsewhere it's very common to see
this in Chinese and there's a special
class of words a small class particles
that help you disambiguate when you need
to
they're called empty words in Chinese
they don't fit into the categories
verben noun and I'll show you how a
couple of these work there just a few
well you know there are several dozen
but it's few compared to everything else
we might say Venson person plus heart
these are nouns and then we don't know
if we're saying people's hearts and
minds or people and hearts oh I see I've
got the parts of speech reversed here
people and hearts should be in in
people's hearts and minds is basically
minds hearts and minds described by
people associated with people if we need
to specify which of these two things we
mean we have a particle we can stick in
the middle both of these forms appear
all over the place in the texts
renditions that tells us that it is the
shin the hearts associated with people
that disambiguates when we need to we
can stick these little particles in
here's another one sure deep it could be
two noun phrases coordinate seasons and
sacrifice or it could be seasonal
sacrifice in which sack
is the main point and season really
describes it it could be to sacrifice
and to do it described by season at the
right season or from season to season or
it could be that time is actually the
verb and it means to make timely the
sacrifices and there might even be other
possibilities but this will do for for
things how do you know what it means
well context but if context won't help
you the author can put in a particle to
help you and they would do it like this
eg both of these phrases appear again
all over the literature so it means to
sacrifice at correct times um
digression what is this context-free
grammar anyway what a crazy name why did
he call it this well he didn't he called
it a phrase structure which was actually
clearer being free of context has to do
with the fact that these rules can apply
to anything that can be fed into them
anything that can be put in his input
doesn't matter if it's a whole sentence
or a tiny little subpart can be put in
and you don't need to think about what
surrounds the word or the words but the
context in order to conduct the analysis
in order to run the rule and get output
he wanted to have a rule so that if you
had a sentence the man ate the food and
the food was eaten by the man there
would be a way to relate these like the
ate and was eaten and all the other
differences and for this reason he
produced and described and and and
promulgated transformational grammar eat
and eat and aged and eaten are different
forms of the same word you you have to
have something complicated to handle
words that have multiple forms the same
word multiple forms furthermore was
eaten you know you've got to have other
words appearing like was to be eaten you
can't say to be eat right you have to be
eaten there's all of this change that
has to take place that's context and for
that reason for a language like English
you need if not transformational grammar
then something come
to it well classical Chinese does not
have these features anywhere it never
changes the form of its words ever and
never requires one or two extra things
to make sense out of it so classical
Chinese is not of the order of
complexity of your typical natural
language by which you know in the
Chomsky school English is the only thing
we always we structuralists always said
they only knew English so classical
Chinese is not of the order of
complexity of a language like English
that requires a transformational grammar
it can be succinctly and fully described
the core can be fully described by a
context-free grammar it is like a
programming language in that respect in
that extreme simplicity so I've got a
recap of the important points what I
don't want to do is run out of time
before there are time for questions so
that's really the end of the talk this
will be posted soon and you can argue
with me I do want to thank the people
who particularly ROS Ames who bullied me
into submitting this talk she didn't
think I'd be accepted but there you are
however I do want to point out if you're
a specialist in Chinese or in
linguistics if you want to argue with me
I love it I have six points or seven
points for contention at the end of this
these slides and there are more that we
could handle so do look at the slides or
come and fight with me I'm here until
Sunday night and I did promise you some
examples of nouns changing into verbs
and so on so I tried to do this quickly
and the software didn't cooperate too
much but the Sun appears in the east Sun
a noun look at the bottom level of this
tree son and emerge that means well it
means the Sun emerges but we need it to
be a noun so we say the emergence of the
Sun the sun's emerge
the sun's rising and to be located at
the east okay it takes place in the east
okay and you put it together this is an
example of Sun being now I'll give this
to you just to whet your appetite for
son being a verb and here it is not to
last a day son day becomes a verb when
it's negated a negative particle is like
a verb it turns the verb the word that
follows it into a noun
rather into a verb to do not day it
means to not last a day it has to do not
last today once you have the negative
before it it becomes a verb to last a
day and so this is to complete it under
the conditions of not lasting a day and
this is you know from other philosopher
Mencius he says the people will get the
work done in a day okay this is an
example of you see you see day you see
son you say well that's it now I know
that's announced as safe now it's not
safe you negate it it's a verb right
away
furthermore it and the negative are
simply modifying something that come
after it the state of true and I said
there's a verb to behave as appropriate
in the state of Chu and there's a great
one liner in mensches here eat ah Archy
true okay
so de to be to subordinating particle to
seek his her to behave as in Chu so I
couldn't get this all on to one tree
this was a lot of my life was spent
trying to do that
yes latech is wonderful everything seems
easier after let's have your top
so de+ to beat this is to beat daily
anybody here have children okay
we use the subordinating particle to
tell us that Utah is going to describe
how whatever comes after is done seek
cheat rule the situation that they
behave as they should ensure their
chewing it says his or her behaving as
in chew to beat daily under those
circumstances to seek they're behaving
as they should ensure in other words to
beat daily thus to seek them to behave
as they should ensure to want your
children to behave as in true as though
intial even if you beat them daily and
he's gonna say it's no use that's what
he's going to say okay I had a famous
Confucian saying too but I think it's
more important to get questions under
way so let's move to questions anything
special I need to do okay so here's the
problem with questions if you're in the
back I may not see you raise your hand
and I may not hear so if back questions
come up if they could be forwarded
loudly by the audience it would help but
I'll start in the front where did I see
a hand second row please
yeah so I contend that if you don't
worry about the particles particles are
viewed as disambiguating to some extent
then no sentences should be no observed
sentences should be ruled out there
shouldn't be anything that's produced
well there shouldn't be anything that's
not produced that should be produced
let's put it that way so what there's
two questions I don't want to use this
to produce actual strings I want to use
this to parse strings so the question is
does a string get fed in that cannot be
parsed and the true answer is it depends
on how you have defined your words
because if you've defined something as a
noun in such a way that it's not clear
to you how it becomes a verb then you're
stuck if you just say son you don't
understand how it is to last for a day
but in principle everything that you
encounter should be describable by these
eight patterns yes another question I
see you in the middle
yes
yes if you say you know the bear eatin
the man it's not a correct sentence
anymore so was and by are not
functioning the way particles do in
classical Chinese particles are in
theory at least optional they
disambiguate what could be a viable
sentence without their presence now once
you get to very long sentences you never
see them without particles so it's kind
of moot but when we examine small groups
of two three four five characters if we
eliminate particles from there the rules
that I've described still cover all the
cases whereas in English you if you
don't change each to eaten or to ate in
a different situation you don't have a
grammatical sentence anymore that's
that's the issue okay yeah trying to
find lots of people in different places
blue in the middle please yes well I
wish I did some of the particles are
themselves ambiguous whoever invented
this language you know there was a
theory among the Jesuits in the 18th
century that this the written language
was invented by a sage to be a written
language I forgotten that the priests
name who came up with this and he was
just treated as insane but when you
think about how condensed and
telegraphic this is it really looks like
somebody thought a lot about how to
write it's hard to believe that what we
have here correspond to something that
people you know discursively and
redundantly used orally but about the
the ambiguity of the particles some of
the particles are themselves full words
in certain contexts so like let me get
back here too
well well this one the Jew this one the
middle one this means to go it does not
mean the person went to the heart well
it it could you know if heart was a
place then it could be people went to
she the place she and it could mean that
so the particles there's not a huge
number but their behavior you have to
learn by learning many examples and
forgetting a sense I think the thing
that in the classroom in Chinese cities
and Chinese speaking countries the
problem is that you're expected to
memorize lots of examples whereas
thinking about the types of words is
more associated with what happened in
the United States in the 40s and 50s
with the structuralist movement parts of
speech were not described in Chinese
traditionally until a Jesuit educated
person began writing a grammar about 120
years ago yes please in the front
okay mm-hmm yes I'm not ruling it out
I'm absolutely not I'm just quickly
trying to give an example of the Sun as
a noun I absolutely thought about should
I give both derivations here or not
there's a reason why two plus two is to
be favored it is not Universal but one
of the things that you cannot do with a
context-free grammars talk about prosody
which is the effect of sound on the
order of language and in Chinese there's
a very strong tendency for things to
come in twos and fours and for fours to
be made of pairs of two and so your tool
you don't it happens that this line
comes from a series of four character
expressions in the litchi in the
particular book and for that reason when
I read it I feel it's twos true is an
expression it's a clear expression the
emergence of the Sun sunrise and so on
but true you don't absolutely to emerge
in the East yes that is certainly a
legitimate way the thing is it's
ambiguous so we have to choose I chose
in this case based on prosody but you
are in no way wrong and I don't exclude
it no not at all how are we for time
pretty much done can we have one more
all these people asking questions who
was it there would go black shirt in the
middle
yes okay so Mandarin definitely contains
this system but it's a superset it has
for instance a much larger application
of particles so unless you're speaking
in a very formal way you don't speak or
write without particles so this sure
that we mentioned this thing between
person and heart if you need it in
Mandarin you need it it has to be there
it's like the was in was eaten if you
don't have it in there you are using
ungrammatical Mandarin that's an example
there are verb final particles that are
four or five important ones that
describe aspect which is the state in
which a verb is is it done is it
undergoing is it not yet started there
are a bunch of those and they are
particles that cannot be dispensed with
those are two examples and in Mandarin
there's also the separation of units we
have so Co verb object phrases sometimes
have great distance between one thing
and another thing and they actually need
to be understood together it's not like
well it's not like in French where you
have the verb pas and verb clear you
have all of these ways of negating for
which you need two things that are
physically separated but it's of that
type that there are separated things
that need to be understood together and
there are suffixes no Mandarin is not a
pure descendant of the written language
classical Chinese it has first of all
it's a spoken language with all of all
of that entails and second it's clear
that in the north it hasn't been only
influenced by Chinese forces it's been
influenced by other languages as well I
fear to keep you past your coffee so
thank you for your attention and your
patience